[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai un secret à vous livrer
j'aime les graines
j'adore ça mais pas n'importe quelle
graine
ces graines font partie de la troisième
plus vaste famille de plantes au monde
des plantes que l'homme cultive depuis
les débuts de l'agriculture depuis la
nuit des temps
si je vous dis le petit pois
le pois chiche
la lentille
le lupin la féverole le soja et bien
d'autres encore
et bien ce sont des légumineuses ou des
légumes secs
mais arrières grands-parents étaient des
anciens cultivateurs près de Lannion
dans le Trégor en Bretagne il consommait
régulièrement des légumineuses en purée
ou potage à la table du quotidien
ils ont cultivé aussi
en pâturage en prairie en fourrage pour
nourrir leur animaux d'élevage pourtant
nous avons délaissé depuis plusieurs
décennies les légumineuses la France est
l'un des plus petits pays consommateurs
au monde de ces graines un français en
consomme moins de 2 kg par an c'est près
de 4 fois moins que la moyenne mondiale
près de 4 fois moins qu'il y a 100 ans
et près de 5 fois moins que les
préconisations des autorités publiques
alors
pourquoi n'aime-t-on plus les
légumineuses pourquoi ce désamour
des raisons historiques des décisions
géopolitiques des arbitrages
macroéconomiques ont plutôt privilégié
d'autres espèces plus compétitives plus
rentable plus robuste
pour les agriculteurs les légumineuses
sont économiquement peu attractives les
revenus générés sont instables les
niveaux de production sont inférieurs à
ceux d'autres cultures comme les
céréales ou lesagineux en raison de la
forte sensibilité des légumineuses aux
aléas météorologiques aux maladies aux
insectes sans compter certaines
difficultés de récolte ou de stockage
quant aux industriels l'inconvénient des
légumineuses réside dans le manque de
procédés technologiques pour transformer
ses graines en des produits conformes
aux attentes des consommateurs et pour
les consommateurs que nous sommes nous
pensons souvent que les légumineuses
sont indigestes insipides et longues à
préparer
mais moi j'ai décidé de dire non non non
non parce que aujourd'hui n'est pas la
fin des haricots
nourrir en qualité et en quantité
l'humanité tout en minimisant notre
empreinte environnementale c'est une
priorité nécessaire pour bien vivre
demain le futur de notre alimentation
est au menu de nombreuses problématiques
de société
notre façon de manger va devoir évoluer
et déjà en train d'évoluer pour tout un
tas de raisons de santé écologique des
préoccupations financières ou éthiques
j'ai pris conscience
que malgré leur apparence banale les
légumineuses sont des graines d'avenir
et à travers trois arguments je vais
vous convaincre d'en mettre davantage
dans vos assiettes
tout d'abord
les légumineuses sont les ingrédients
d'une alimentation saine naturelle et
équilibrée
contempler par vous-même
la teneur en protéines des graines de
légumineuses et un de leur atout
nutritionnel majeur
par exemple
prenez 100 g de viande un pavé de steak
26% de protéines pour la même quantité
de légumineuses le haricots rouges 10%
de protéines et pour la même quantité en
céréales le blé 6% de protéines 26% de
protéines pour la viande 10% pour
légumineuse le haricot et 6% pour le blé
la teneur en protéines des légumineuses
est donc inférieure à celle de la viande
et supérieure à celle des céréales c'est
pour ça qu'il est intéressant d'associer
un tiers de légumineuses avec deux tiers
de céréales dans son assiette pour
couvrir nos besoins en acides aminés
essentiels
c'est d'ailleurs un des principes
utilisés dans le cadre d'un régime
végétarien pour remplacer tout au parti
les protéines animales par des protéines
végétales et c'est potentiellement d'ici
2050 en réintroduisant davantage de
légumineuses dans nos repas que nous
pourrons peut-être accélérer la
transition alimentaire de nos régimes
carnés faire une consommation plus
frugale et qualitative de protéines
animales
mais la teneur en protéines des graines
de légumineuses n’est pas leur seule
argument nutritif elles ont également
d'autres caractéristiques intéressantes
elles sont pauvres en matières grasses
riches en fibres alimentaires de qualité
ce qui permet d'équilibrer de
diversifier notre microbiote intestinal
elles sont également riches en sucre
lents en vitamines en minéraux notamment
en fer qui permet de procurer une
énergie de choix pour votre cerveau et
vos muscles oui
les légumineuses elles sont également
sans gluten un aliment idoine pour les
personnes intolérantes ou allergiques et
chaque graine apporte ses propres
oligo-éléments de manière complémentaire
ce qui permet en fait de combler nos
besoins que l'on retrouve assez peu en
général dans notre alimentation et qui
sont très importants à l'organisme d'où
l'intérêt de diversifier les espèces de
légumineuses dans son alimentation
de part ce panel de propriété
nutritionnelles les légumineuses
présents de nombreux bienfaits pour la
santé elles permettent de diminuer la
prévalence de certains types de cancers
maladies cardiovasculaires aux maladies
chroniques comme le diabète ou l'obésité
les légumineuses sont donc les
ingrédients d'une alimentation saine
équilibrée et naturelle
mais ce ne sont pas seulement que des
supers aliments
ce sont également des cultures
respectueuses de l'environnement
la toux des légumineuses par rapport à
l'environnement c'est qu'elles
permettent de réaliser des économies
d'intrants azotées
l'azote c'est le carburant des plantes
quand il y a pas d'azote il y a pas
d'agriculture et lorsque dans certaines
situations agronomiques il y a une
carence en azote dans le sol
l'agriculteur apporte souvent des
engrais azotés principalement de
synthèse pour satisfaire les besoins de
la plante
cependant dans certaines situations
lorsqu'il y a une offre excessive en
azote cela peut générer des problèmes
environnementaux risque de pollution des
cours d'eau émission de gaz à effet de
serre et voire même des problèmes
économiques pour les producteurs
les légumineuses elles sont une solution
à ces problèmes
elles n'ont pas besoin d'engrais azotées
grâce à une symbiose entre les bactéries
du sol et les racines de la plante qui
lui permettent de fixer l'azote de l'air
gratuitement et de le restituer au sol
après le passage des légumineuses les
cultures suivantes l'année d'après ou
deux ans après blé orge colza maïs
pourront à leur tour gratuitement aller
puiser dans ce stock d'azote qui a été
mobilisé par la légumineuse permettant
l'agriculteur de réaliser des économies
d'azote de manière non négligeable tout
en pouvant bénéficier d'une production
sécurisée et satisfaisante
au-delà de la gestion de l'azote les
légumineuses ont également un impact
intéressant sur la biodiversité
elle permet de diversifier les rotations
culturales qui sont principalement
dédiées en Europe aux céréales ou
lesagineux grâce à cette diversification
elles vont permettre de casser le cycle
biologique de maladies d'insectes de
plantes indésirables et par ce fait de
diminuer l'application de traitement
phytosanitaire autrement dit les
pesticides
de par également leur structure
racinaire ces plantes permettent de
préserver la qualité des sols et de
diminuer l'érosion
dans le contexte du changement
climatique
les légumineuses sont également un
levier intéressant pour s'adapter par
rapport à l'accélération des épisodes de
sécheresse
certaines des espèces de cette grande
famille
peuvent être cultivées dans des zones
arides ou semi-arides comme au
Moyen-Orient ce n'est pas le cas de
toutes les espèces mais certaines
espèces de légumineuses sont tout à fait
adaptés à des sols pauvres en eau ils
peuvent résister à ses aimants à des
épisodes longs de sécheresse
il est intéressant dans un contexte une
France en surchauffe de réintroduire là
où agronomiquement cela fait sens là où
le climat est le sol le permettent de
réintroduire ces espèces pour pouvoir
diminuer l'effort d'irrigation et avoir
une gestion adaptative par rapport à un
bien commun à une denré précieuse qui
est devenue vraiment cruciale qui est
l'eau
enfin elles sont aussi un atout
indéniable
en ce qu'elle permette de décarboner de
manière partielle mais de manière quand
même non négligeable l'agriculture
française
quand vous vous promenez le dimanche en
campagne vous avez peut-être vu des
prairies de trèfle de luzerne et de
Saint foin ce sont des légumineuses
fourragères parce qu'elles sont
valorisées plantes entières par des
vaches par des ruminants et elles soient
constitue un stock de protéines très
intéressant pour l'alimentation du
bétail
et les animaux comme les humains ont des
besoins de protéines et jusqu'à
maintenant historiquement ce sont des
importations d'aliments concentrées
riches en protéines qui vont satisfaire
cette fourniture protéique pour
sécuriser l'alimentation animale en
France
mais ce modèle là n'est pas forcément le
plus soutenable et il est intéressant de
réintroduire de cultiver davantage de
légumineuses en les relocalisant dans
nos territoires comme c'était le cas il
y a près d'un siècle
et de pouvoir diminuer la dépendance
protéique de nos éleveurs de pouvoir
diminuer les émissions de carbone étant
de décarboner en ce sens l'agriculture
tout en permettant aux éleveurs d'être
plus sécurisés et plus efficient face à
la volatilité des marchés mondiaux
les légumineuses elles sont donc
intéressantes pour la santé des humains
elles sont également bonnes pour la
santé de la planète
mais ce sont aussi les sentinelles de la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale
pour la même quantité de viande et de
protéines les légumineuses sont souvent
moins chers
on en produit en France ou des labels de
qualité appellation d'origine contrôlée
indications Géographique Protégée c'est
le cas de la lentille du Berry de la
mogette de Vendée du Linko des lingots
du Nord du Harry Potter Bay et tout
proche d'ici du coco paimpolais
manger davantage du légumineuses c'est
enrichir son alimentation sans alourdir
son budget
et puis ces graines elles se conservent
facilement dans le temps elles sont
facilement transportables stockables
leur propriété nutritionnelle se
conservent aisément dans la durée et
étant donné finalement leurs impacts
positifs pour la santé des humains et
aussi bien sur les agroécosystèmes les
pays émergents et les pays du Sud ont
depuis longtemps adopté les légumineuses
à contrario de nous pays industrialisés
légumineuses sont un aliment de base de
répertoire alimentaire dans ces pays et
c'est en ce sens qu'on les qualifie de
sentinelle de gardiennes de la
souveraineté alimentaire mondiale
puisque étant donné la large diversité
génétique de ces espèces on peut au
moins cultiver son n'importe quel type
de climat ou de sol une ou plusieurs
espèces de légumineuses
une étude récente montrée l'année
dernière que la moitié des Français
déclarait au moins manger une fois par
semaine des légumineuses c'est une
première depuis longtemps c'est un
signal positif les légumineuses sont en
tendance
elle retrouve leur lettre de noblesse
et il existe une diversité d'espèces de
légumineuses de lentilles de poids on
peut les décliner en entrée en collation
en accompagnement et même en dessert
ne soyez pas surpris si vous voyez des
légumineuses dans des menus
gastronomiques ou des chefs étoilés les
remèdes au goût du jour en mettant les
petits plats dans les grands
et puis entre nous
vous pouvez laisser un moment à
l'instant le fameux traditionnel
dominical saucisses lentilles qui
ravitant belle-maman pour pouvoir aller
s'inspirer avoir un élan de créativité
dans d'autres cultures culinaires
et oui vive le houmous vivent le ragoût
de haricots rouges vive la fête du
Brésil ou encore et bien le daladien
qu'on peut cultiver donc on peut
cuisiner au curry au lait de coco à
toutes les sauces
j'espère vous avoir convaincu que malgré
leur apparence banale les légumineuses
sont des graines d'avenir saines
écologiques pratiques sentinelle de la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale
elles sont nos alliés dans un contexte
multicris que nous traversons climatique
écologique économique
des efforts ont été faits jusqu'à
maintenant
et continuer d'être fait
dans les prochaines décennies il sera
très important de continuer à mettre les
bouchées doubles pour créer développer
pérenniser les filières ambitieuses de
légumineuses en France
il existe différentes solutions du champ
à l'assiette de la fourche à la
fourchette toutes les solutions sont
interconnectées mais en existe une qui
est un des diablement la plus importante
qui permettra que la recette des
légumineuses puissent rencontrer le
succès qu'elle mérite
c'est un ingrédient il est tout
simplement présent ici aujourd'hui
c'est vous c'est nous en tant que
citoyen consommateur
mettre davantage de légumineuses dans
son assiette ce n'est pas uniquement bon
pour la santé
des humains de la planète et également
de son portefeuille c'est aussi
s'engager dans une démarche de
consommation responsable c'est mieux
manger pour mieux produire pour mieux
vivre dans un environnement de qualité
qui puisse bénéficier durablement à tous
c'est pour ça que je vous propose à
votre tour comme moi est-ce que vous
deviez des ambassadeurs des légumineuses
un poids c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]